hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday July 10th
2020 tree what's going on how why yeah
how's it going how's it going in your
your your part of the woods I'm supposed
to tease something
without saying what it is because the
show is going to be announced on Tuesday
but I'm not supposed to tell you what it
is but I'm supposed to tease you I'm
supposed to tickle you under your
[__] chin with a little bit of
information all right I am going to be
doing a show and they try in the
tri-state area
at a very well-known
uh
establishment
[Music]
I've done the establishment before all
right I'm gonna be doing it in November
but I am not allowed to say the name of
the venue
I don't understand this
this is like a certain streaming service
that you're not allowed to say you know
when when you have a project coming out
it's like you cannot say when it is
coming out until halfway through next
Thursday
it's only Monday oh my God what if you
[__] say what if you put that
information out three and a half days
earlier are people not gonna go see it
are they not going to go to the show I
don't understand it but you know if I've
learned anything in life
it's to keep my mouth shut and not think
for myself
and let the sociopaths that effortlessly
Ascend the ladder of power because they
have no [__] empathy whatsoever just
listen to them they know what to do
um
anyway [__] flew back from uh
Atlantic City via Philadelphia yesterday
uh by the way Philadelphia exciting City
to see
you come around the corner on the
highway and there it is that's a [__]
you know there's a lot of you know
you know what I'm saying I'm sick of
every time there's a sporting event they
have to go up to the biggest [__]
mouth breather
in Philadelphia
hit on 10 chicks and I have a little
dick I don't give a [__] you seen that
one it's just like is it always that guy
the guy with no self-esteem complete
[__] [__]
those guys from Always Sunny are from
Philadelphia right
I worked at Denver first three of the
smartest guys I ever met they're from
Philadelphia
I talked to one of them he watched the
Marx Brothers growing up that's what the
smart kids did the dummies like me
watched The Three Stooges I refuse to
believe that everybody in Philly is that
[__] stupid I go there they're not
that stupid you go to a sporting event
I just feel like it's it's just like uh
they feel like they have to do it like
you know when a celebrity like sort of
builds
you know
like a Belushi or something they build
their life around Chris Farley like
being that guy then all of a sudden they
get trapped they feel like they have to
be there I feel like Philly sports fans
are like that
it's like all the cameras on I have to
rep Philly
let me go let me [__] uh deep throat
a Cheesesteak and then go puke on a cop
you know or whatever the [__] it is
they're doing I just I don't know
I still like the city you know
anyway so we yeah we were driving down
from Allentown but yesterday uh I gotta
give a shout out to American Airlines
we were uh leaving the patent and I was
really nervous that we were going to get
stuck there because of the global
warming that for whatever reason they're
not talking about last week I got stuck
for eight hours because of these insane
[__] storms
with lightning and all of this [__] and
uh
you know I'm getting calls from
comedians around the country I can't get
out of Oklahoma I can't get out of Vegas
you know
and I've been doing the road long enough
this [__] didn't happen it didn't it
didn't like on this level
like I got three dip calls from
different comics in different parts of
the country saying the weather was too
[__] for them to get out of there so I
just have to hold on to the fact that
they're going to figure this out and
somehow they're going to fix it but
anyway so last week I ended up with Dean
Del Rey
we did what we did we did Hershey we did
Newark
um and we did Bridgeport Connecticut we
had a great time we go to Newark Airport
we say goodbye to club soda Kenny and
thus began
you know eight and a half hours of
delays while they had to wait for the
lightning and all this stuff
to go away right so the whole time
you know
um
Saturday night or whatever
I was thinking like man I just wish they
had red eyes going the other way
you know they only have red eyes going
from west to east I wish they had one I
would step off stage here in Atlantic
City I'd go [__] jump in a car go
right to the Philly Airport
you know and then go to sleep
but nope I didn't I had like a 10 49 a.m
flight we get there it's looking
overcast it's cool doesn't seem like the
temperature's High I'm like all right
here we go we're going to get out of
here we get on the [__] plane we push
away from the gate at 10 49 this is all
[__] good we're out on the taxiway
and
Bam the dude pulls over
let me tell you something when they pull
over they never get back on the taxiway
to go to the runway they always pull
over and they said we're just gonna shut
it down here for a second
we got a little bit of weather out there
first of all once that happens
then you had like
you have to wait to get clearance as far
as my limited understand you have to
wait to get clearance again
and that involves resubmitting your IFR
flight plan and you have to get let back
into the system and the system is
tracking all flights along your path to
make sure that at no point are you gonna
[__]
smash into somebody else
or whatever so
long story short
the guy goes all right you know actually
it's looking up they're gonna try to
oh actually it isn't and then look it up
look at it and then all of a sudden he's
just like ah I got some bad news here me
and my co-pilot just timed out as we
flew up here from Miami this morning we
got to take you back to the gate and uh
we got to get you another flight crew
unfortunately I don't have any more
information which is the number one
thing
the number one thing said in aviation
other than sir can you please take your
seat is
I don't we don't have any more I don't
have any more information
ma'am is there any way you can turn down
the intercom no there's nothing I can do
there's nothing I don't have any more
information you mean to tell me somebody
installed this intercom on 10 and it's
you that's the only option to have so
there's nothing I can do I don't have it
they always do that [__] so if we go
back to the gate and we're getting off
the [__] thing right
at this point I just call Kenny I don't
give a [__] I go dude I'm gonna blow all
my gig money just give me a [__] I'm
not doing this again
all right
I want to go home I want to see my
[__] kids just get me a [__] joke
oh it's gonna be all your gig money I
don't give a [__] right
so we're just sitting there I'm [__]
eating a burrito and I'm just standing
there
you know and it was funny I didn't even
talk to the gate agent everybody else
did she's like I'm sorry I don't have
any information uh well there's no
information if there's information I
don't have it right and she's just
standing there
so me and [__] Dean get the burrito
and then Dane eyes light up he goes dude
there's a pilot there's another one they
get I don't know where the [__] these
guys were we got off the plane and 20
minutes later American Airlines had
another flight crew to take us across
I've never had that happen when the
flight crew time's out forget it
you might as well start looking for Real
Estate
you might as well start looking for real
estate in that area because you are not
going to be [__] leaving
and it's until the next [__] day I'm
sorry there's nothing we could do uh you
have a voucher for this hotel the
hotel's sold out I'm sorry you're gonna
have to figure it out
I gotta figure it out
um
but American Airlines had a flight crew
we got back on you know it wasn't too
bad I was only like a two three hour
delay but I was just going like I am
literally going to get home at like
[__] one in the morning my kids are
going to be asleep
and I already faceted him I said I was
gonna come home ride bikes play with
them and all of that stuff so I had a
little moment I didn't believe in
American Airlines and God damn it they
came through we're American Airlines
getting you a new flat crew
um
so anyway I had a great
great trip uh back east
um in Allentown live in here in
Allentown you know I went there and I
was expecting to see a Rust Belt City or
the remnants of it I was expecting to
see the big Factory or whatever and it
wasn't there and I was kind of talking
to people you know when you go into town
there is sort of this giant looks like a
Church of Satan
you know you could see at one point it
was beautiful but now that it's kind of
run down it's taken on this ominous vibe
was still really cool and then right
after
um you went past that big building there
was all of these houses like next to
each other like when they used to run
the end credits at the end of uh All in
the Family and I was thinking like these
were probably the workers houses
you know they got them all right next to
each other God forbid they get they get
a little bit of [__]
they get a yard to stretch their legs
out on right
and I built this whole thing up and
people like yeah no that's not what it
was and
I didn't know what they would you know I
was doing the show so I couldn't quite
hear what they were saying but ended up
looking up that song Billy Joel they've
been here in Allentown it was actually
about Bethlehem
Pennsylvania
and just Allentown sounded better
so that's what he did and that's back
before social media Sonoma could go
you know on the internet and trash Billy
Joe and be like oh hey [__] stick uh
there's actually no [__] Rust Belt
[__] here uh I think you're either
talking about Bethlehem [__]
something else or something else
um by the way
I am uh my latest addiction my [__]
cell phone I am really trying to just uh
I've gotten back into reading books
I was in a car the other day or
something in this this city bus went by
you know you got the big [__] windows
and every single person they went by was
just staring at their phone now I think
that's great for public transportation
okay the more people are staring at
their phones and not looking at each
other I feel like the less fights there
are
you know like back in the day it'd be
like you could only look at like the the
advertisement and Subway signage for so
long before your eyes came down and they
met somebody else's eyes who was then
just the [__] are you looking at and
then there was a thing now everybody's
just staring at their phones
um
I swear to God you could stab somebody
in the neck like four times before
anybody would even notice
Leicester persons started kicking their
legs like that police officer in the
beginning of No Country for Old Men
and was leaving the black MOX on the
floor
um
so anyway and I also noticed like I go
on social media and the level of [__]
like this this sort of this this new
toxic self-help out there
you know where first of all everybody's
like given like this life advice and
it's just like what is your life I gotta
see what your life is that you've
applied this and that it works
are you even a therapist like who the
[__] are you right and now it's become
like this sort of aggressive self-help
where they they put this panic in you
like a used car salesman hey I got
another guy coming down to look at it in
20 minutes right
um
like the you know in the last in the
last 30 seconds you just aged 40 seconds
thinking of think about that you know
but if you eat you know my liver I went
to the doctor my liver I'm 51 my liver
is 65 but after taking this stuff my
liver is Now 37 and I'm 26 my dick works
again and I'm [__] it's like what is
this [__]
it was something about kids going like
90 of the free time you have to play
with your kids happens before they're
nine years old 45 of that happens before
they're five
it's just like what is this [__]
first of all what is this what is this
for it's just
and I just get off there going like oh
my God I'm a fat [__] who doesn't spend
enough time with this kid who's uh
[__] liver is beyond his age and blah
blah it's like I want to go back they
should have like you know they have like
uh you know what bands every every three
years somebody's bringing it back
you know Lenny Kravitz he's bringing it
back
jet they're bringing it back and there's
always a rock band that's bringing it
back Lenny Kravitz came out and he was
like [__] that wireless [__] I'm using
the old Marshalls with the coil thing
[__] uh I don't know that like as far
as rock music there's been a band every
[__] six years is bringing it back
right
they should do that with social media
like I want to go back to Old School
social media where it was just watching
someone get kicked in the balls or
watching somebody butcher slashes solo
on Sweet Child of Mine like just
somebody getting shot with a BB gun in
the middle of a river is he screams
before his voice changes remember that
one
that fat guy on the [__] dirt bike he
went to go over the jump I think that's
still on my MySpace page I just don't
know how to get to it
it was just fun it was
you know what I sound like I sound like
old rappers you know when they talk
about like the early days of hip-hop
like man it was just fun it was just a
party you know
but that they used to say that when it
then it became like gangster rap and
there was like all of that all of that
[__] drama going on
um before now now what is is it the
drugged out I have no idea what's going
on I just know if you just say
if you just say they're drinking lean
you can kind of sustain yourself in the
conversation for about eight seconds
before people know you have no idea what
you're talking about
um
anyway but I think also
uh
uh that music and all of that stuff
always gets defined the same way Philly
the people of Philadelphia get defined
by that Upper Deck [__] [__] who's
at least 18 beers in
you know how they get defined by that I
think today's
um
like probably all all straight across
music did this [__] great music out
there it's just everybody's focusing on
the pop [__] which you know
has always sucked right
I loved a nightlife I got to a boogie on
the desk girl around oh yes it was
always [__]
that's always been that [__]
and then there's been like real [__]
going on
that a smaller segment
I don't know
I'm just watching and I I was doing it
for a while and I hope you guys have
noticed I've stopped doing it I was
becoming the old guy that was saying
everything even though I'm saying I want
to go back to social media that doesn't
make me feel like I'm I'm a bad dad you
know
I just want to see somebody get hit in
the nuts or or attempt something
you know that's why that fail army [__]
you know for the most part is still just
the is the easy listening
of like uh of the social medias I think
um anyway
I just forgot what my [__] point was
I was talking about oh yeah
how like I love how any time this you
you post any clip of Comedy from back in
the day like old people like me gotta
sit there going you can never [__] do
this yeah people would be [__] faking
on the sidewalk grabbing their [__]
General neutral generals it's like
people have always complained comedians
have always gotten in trouble
I sat down I thought about them like
this this it's just it's just easier to
[__] and it's easier to see back in the
day
if some came out people didn't like the
networks telephones
systems like broke with all of the
people calling in upset about whatever
whatever episode of whatever show just
came out or whoever hosted you know SNL
or whatever happened on The Tonight Show
they would get a flood of calls but we
as regular people
couldn't read the phone calls couldn't
hear him couldn't see him that's why it
just seems like Lenny brute as far as
committees Lenny Bruce got in trouble
he got arrested George Carlin got
arrested [__] prior got in trouble
Kennison got in trouble Dice Clay
got in trouble
all the way through there's just been
that's always happened like a comedian
puts out the [__] special
somebody doesn't like it somebody flips
out
blah blah blah blah that that has always
been happening people have always been
seeing Super Bowl halftime shows all the
way back to [__] Janet Jackson
that was 20 years ago people didn't like
that mod doing the [__] abortion
episode
uh I'm sure the people that made The
Jeffersons got [__] for having an
interracial culture what are you
teaching our kids blah blah blah all the
way [__] all the way back to when Nat
King Cole got his own show why are you
giving this black guy a show it's always
[__] happened
all right so there we go so
I'm just gonna live in this auto-tuned
world
[Laughter]
try to be a nice guy
um
so we did Allentown had such a [__]
great time it's a uh it was actually the
flyest
uh minor league
uh hockey arena so those things are
always great they're always like the
perfect
like sort of size they they kind of look
how like
probably the spectrum look back in the
day where the fans were on top of the
game so I really felt like the crowd was
like on top of me and you could just
have a killer show but
um then we went to Atlantic City
and uh I just sat on on the boardwalk
for like two days
and I'm still post mushroom High
you know so I'm just looking at
everybody in like a positive way and
everything and I had [__] empathy for
these people as they're walking down the
thing but I you know not gonna lie to
you I was like making fun of them on
stage or whatever but like
um
you know as much as these politicians
just sit there and they walk around and
they talk about they still gas up this
country about
you know how great a country and it is
and everything like that but I have to
be honest with you you know there's a
lot of talk about how we treat our
veterans and homeless people in drug
addicts and all that type of [__] I'll
be I I would throw just the average
[__] person in there
if you just saw the lack of Education
walking up and down that Boardwalk uh
just in a nutritional sense
like what people don't know about what
you should eat and what you should not
eat and then the amount of dads that did
not stick around to raise their
daughters
to not walk down the [__] goddamn
dude there was like I mean I'm talking
like it looked like Jerome Bettis in a
[__] bikini within like a fishnet
thing over the top of it well that's
actually insulting probably Jerome now
now that he's not playing why am I what
I have to suggest that he's fat all
right I'm gonna leave all of that other
Refrigerator Perry that's what it looked
like
the white black and Latino version of
that in like a thong bikini with a belly
actually you don't even need the front
of the bikini because the [__]
the belly's gonna hang down far enough
to hide your bush
and then guys just waddling down the
[__] here they are they're down there
to buy more of that food now having said
that I got a gyro
when I was down there that was
outstanding you guys suggested some
places uh off the beaten path I never
ended up getting there I just had I had
some anything batters to record with
Paul verzi
and uh and then also I rented a drum kit
and I got to jam on it the second day
up on the stage in that empty empty uh
conference room that I was performing at
in Atlantic City
oh and Jim Florentine came down the
first night was [__] awesome
or was it the second night might have
been the second night
first night second night I can't
remember
no first night came down the first night
anyway so I went up there and I got like
they miked up the drums they sounded
unfucking believable and I gotta be
honest with you guys I thought I was
[__] killing it
and I kept looking up at the sound guy
like he's probably thinking like wow man
I mean I knew he was good at stand-up
comedy but God damn this guy should play
in a band and uh Kenny took some video
of it
and I was like I could post this [__]
people will be like wow man that's
[__] cool and I watched it and I was
just like what the f what am I hearing
in my head versus what I'm seeing in
this video
ah
it was [__] it just [__] ruined it
didn't ruin it but I mean I I played
better than I did but I always think I'm
[__] like
you know [__] rocking out and
slamming the drums and then I look at
myself and say boom okay
it's just [__] ugh
embarrassing shut it off
so anyway
um
I ended up finally getting home
oh here's a uh
here's a travel tip for you
all right I was flying out when I was
flying out uh
from La out to wherever the [__] I
knewick I think
um
they had those live flat bed seats I was
like oh my God [__] fantastic right
here's the thing about that after you
have them lie flat before you you bring
them back up again
make sure you you have you know where
your wallet your phone and your keys are
because they fall out of your pockets
and if they go underneath that [__]
thing
and you you bring it back up like an
accordion you're gonna have to spend 20
minutes trying to find it which is what
happened to me and this poor woman in
front of I found my wallet before Dean
Del Rey found it
um first it's funny you know you think
you're up in first class until you look
under the seat you're like oh my God
Jesus Jesus
um and we we helped that woman for like
10 minutes 15 minutes look for her phone
and we just could not [__] find it
um
anyway just just add your little travel
tip there for you
um so
anyway I'm still I'm gonna still stick
with the drums
I brought my little jazz book out there
you know
played a little bit of that and uh they
got me this killer Ludwig kit
you know with some Zildjian K's and uh
sounded amazing I had to crank the snare
up a little bit but whoever tuned him up
there he kind of put him right
everything was at the low end
which I thought was really
a great thing because then if I want you
know it's so much easier to tune [__] up
than to have to for anyway for me to
have to like drop it back down again
and um
I listened to some you know on the plane
I was I listened to that Massey Hall
concert
with uh Max Roach
Charlie Parker art Blakey and I'm
starting to understand like a little bit
like these different eras of jazz it's
kind of like the same with like rock
where like
you know it goes through periods of
speeding up
slowing down being more
palable to the masses being more
underground going away people saying
it's dead somebody bringing it back
um
you know like I didn't I thought I knew
I didn't even understand what Bebop was
I thought I knew what Bebop was I I
didn't and I never understood the birth
of cool and all these different like
periods of it and now I'm just listening
to it and I'm actually beginning to like
oh yeah that's completely
that's way different
but I didn't realize like I like to beat
Bob drums I like that you know that
phrase it and all that and I didn't
realize like Dude That's like [__]
early days of speed metal like trying to
keep up with those tempos it's like I
can't [__] play I I thought I was
gonna sit there and play along to this
[__] I can barely keep the ride simple
going
laughs
but what I am happy with is my thing for
the longest time
which really hampered my knowledge of it
other than my lack of musical ability
was the the fact that it was that it
wasn't in Stereo was really hard for me
to listen to
um
and now I'm kind of getting
I'm pushing through that
and uh I read this cool thing John
Reilly wrote the drummer not John C
Reilly the amazing actor and musician
um
he was talking about the drummer's role
you know you're listening to the
soloists and they're either building
up to a
you know to a solo or coming down from
it or sort of just cruising and riding
out and you have to understand you have
to listen to them and understand what
that is
um
and then it just seems like but if you
feel like you know you want to bring it
back up again you can try to egg them on
and say some [__] on the drums it's like
just listening to that I was like wow
these guys were drumming the way all the
comics that I admired when I came up
they were like free it's like they had
their act
which was almost like a basic song
structure and they know where it was
going where they were starting or where
they were going to end up but they
didn't know how they were going to get
there and and
I remember the difference between
opening for someone that did it the same
way every single night as far as like
start with this joke I say this joke
this way every night and then that leads
to this joke and this is a Segway
and they just did the whole thing as
opposed to
working with these other guys
that would just go up there and every
time they would go on stage they would
just start talking
and they had there was like this freedom
and I also noticed like the wait staff
was like me like every show they were
like what's going to happen because you
didn't know what was going to happen
even the comic didn't know what was
going to happen I kind of feel like
like that style of music
is like that and uh I don't know I'm
kind of excited to continue uh listening
to stuff like that
um hang on a second what do we got here
oh look who it is
the lovely Nia looking even more lovely
today how are you
um I'm good thank you I wanted to tell
you a little housekeeping thing so I
don't know if you want to pause real
quick what is the housekeeping thing did
I do something wrong uh yeah and you're
out of here
that's it the housekeeping is I'm
cleaning up house starting with you what
what happened so pack your [__]
get the [__] out no no there's just some
people here doing some work so I just
wanted to let you know
all right yeah and I have to go I have a
call at 10 so I gotta go all right
but hi everybody on the Block okay it's
been a while I need to come back on and
answer some
some questions or something yeah don't
you think
all right I think so you want to answer
a question right now I can skip right to
that no I have to
the first thing says cheesesteak
Nia loves the cheese steak Nia favorites
I'll be
I'm going to the gym
the gym
no I'm going to the gym
that's what I was waiting for you to say
all right
see that she wants me to be one of these
fat people walking down that Boardwalk
in Atlantic City
um all right oh you know what I don't
even have any reads this week oh Jesus
[__] probably [__] pig oh oh what
was I well Bill do you think you were
too edgy
shut up Bill all right
yes Andrew's like where the [__] is the
podcast yes I'm texting right now
recording
now
salt Peanuts salt peanuts all right here
we go I'm just gonna read these this
might be a little short but it isn't
really short if you do the math
all right because every 30 minutes you
listen to a podcast it's actually 40
minutes if you think about it okay but
in ninety percent of your quality time
with me was already in the first six
minutes
um
no I'm not doing any advertising which
usually takes me I don't know a good
seven eight minutes depending on how
many well but I also I like to think I
joked my way through it I like to think
the whole thing is entertaining you know
what I mean
uh cheesesteak
all right so last week
I was saying how I was not going to get
a Cheesesteak I finally gave in
um
when I was in Atlantic City
and I got it at White House
all right and I just said that so every
single [__] person in the
Philadelphia area can go oh what the
[__] did you go there for you went to
the wrong place you [__] up blah blah
blah blah I just don't like
I just don't understand
why can't like this is this is something
that's never happened in Philadelphia
all right I got a Cheesesteak oh where
did you go I went so and so oh yeah oh
that's great that never happens well
what the [__] you go there fig you never
you never go to the right place
uh I don't like that place yeah you like
that place I don't like that place
all right so I was saying that I can't
eat those things anymore because it's a
poor quality it's a poor cut of meat
and whatnot I eat all that stuff and I
love it when I'm eating it and then
afterwards I feel like I I literally
have like a I ate a [__] rain boot
so this person is defending
this person actually has the audacity to
defend the cut of meat
that is in a Cheesesteak he's actually
I've read it already
and this person is going to try to
convince me that this is a high quality
cut of meat right and a high quality cut
of meat why would you keep that in a
steakhouse in charge and charge premium
dollar for it when you can [__] send
it through a paper shredder and put
cheese whiz on it and charge [__]
eight bucks for it
all right but here we go this is this
guy's Theory I don't buy it all right
I'm already trying to taint you with my
point of view cheesesteak cheesesteak
meat is shaved ribeye you Ginger [__]
they take the unportioned section of the
rib eye
comes from the yeah the unportioned the
[__] that they don't that they're not
going to serve at a steakhouse
exactly
so it's it's the [__] section of the rib
eye
the rib eye comes from I.E the prime rib
yeah but prime rib isn't a rib eye
you're talking about that entire cut of
[__] meat and within all of that is
all these cuts of meat and certain
certain parts of that steak are worth
more than others because it's a better
quality of meat better tasting more
flavorful and then the [__] on the ends
they sent through a paper [__] and
down your [__] throat with cheese
whiz on it
all right here we go they take the
unportioned section of the rib eye comes
from I.E the prime rib
stick in the freezer for 30 minutes to
stiffen up then slice it thinly using a
deli slicer or a paper shredder uh
you're not feeling sick because of a
mystery meat I wasn't saying it was Mr
medium saying it was a poor quality of
meat uh you're feeling sick because of
the amount of fat and carbs you're
eating from a fatty cut of meat
synthetic yeah fatty cut of meat buddy
exactly
listen you know what you're doing right
now let's just say you got the
Cheesesteak and they all robbed the bank
what's happening right now is the
unportioned section of the rib eye is
trying to cut a deal with the cops to
say hey I'm not I want to get less of a
sentence
I know people died during that Smash and
grab I'm gonna say who they are I'm
gonna say I'm gonna I'm gonna rat them
all out
all right you want me to name names I'll
[__] name names all right the carbs
the it was the cheese synthetic cheese
it was the fried onions and essentially
uh the loaf of bread was the guy who put
it together I was just driving the car
he says anyway anyways best wishes to
your diabetic ass and go [__] yourself
sir um yeah you kind of I you have not
changed
my thoughts whatsoever you know let's
actually look this up because I I used
to look this up and I always found this
fascinating
um
they said like a picture where they
would they would diagram out all the
different like cuts of a steak I mean I
don't know what to look look up here
though uh
um
different cuts
of steak
where they come
from all right here we go
all right
okay here we go
all right the top of the cow
is sirloin mid this is like right in the
middle of its body mid is thin flank
and then briskets at the bottom
then you got Shin this is all in the
bottom this is also the whole expression
of living high on the hog so the higher
up you were on like
a pig or on like a steer you're eating a
better cut of meat
um on the back end you got the thick
flank the rump
uh
I wanted to diagram the whole sticky and
notice that in all of this you don't
hear
cheese steak
it doesn't even come up
like how far into the liner notes of the
[__] thing do I have to go like why
do you have to argue with me on this one
I'm not looking this [__] [__] up
okay
we have in Boston we have what's known
as a steak and cheese and if you're
going to [__] [__] sit there and
try to suggest that that meat is the
same [__] meat I get it a goddamn
Steakhouse in Boston they just froze
it's just the end of one and they froze
it up there's a reason why they do it
all right it doesn't cook as well it's
too fatty blah blah whatever the [__]
the chef reason is for it they removed
it and then they're like well we're
wasting money we need to find a way to
[__] dress this [__] up
and serve it to these people so we can
still make money
or sell it to people that have lesser
restaurants I.E Steak and Shake [__]
places that's what the [__] they do
I'm not getting into this with you buddy
okay you know what it's actually I'm
eating a frozen rib eye that's yeah
that's what it is oh my God
listen I'm not saying it tastes bad I'm
just saying I can't [__] eat it and I
was right I would I want to say I was
right I just want to be right for once
in my life for once in my life I have a
[__] opinion I'd like someone to
listen to
all right Farm's in Independent News
you're probably right but you know what
I I know like nothing starts a debate
like bringing up food
you know global warming people don't
care I mean that's just the end of the
world let's talk about what is on our
sandwiches
um
I can tell you this right now okay if
they had more steakhouses serving actual
Ribeyes on the boardwalk of Atlantic
City those [__] people would not be
looking like that instead of feeding
them more cheesesteaks
dude it's not me man
who's that dude with the six nine on his
face that's what the meat is in that
sandwich just ratting everybody out so I
can get out of [__] prison all right
Farm's in Independent News
uh dear Wicked Willy
I'd like to correct last week's
listeners about the Farmland
confiscation
oh here's somebody works for Buckingham
Palace or some [__] I don't know uh it's
happening in the Netherlands not Norway
oh okay sorry it's blood boiling what's
going on there
the news has tried to smear them as
right wing their story is frustrating
because there is literally no one but
independent new
Outlets that will oh no nobody but
independent news outlets that will give
their side of the story yeah it's
[__] evil
um
I wish more people realized how much
mainstream news
on the conservative side and the we do
new no [__] wrong bleeding heart
[__] [__] liberal side
the liberal side [__] infuriates me
because I'm liberal and I'm watching
these people acting like they give a
[__] about people and they don't and it
drives me up the [__] wall it
everybody on CNN can just just all of
that it's corporate [__] news
all right
sorry
all right you go to Fox News you know
that they only give a [__] about
themselves that's what I expect
um all right also I'd like to add a
glimmer of hope to terrible world media
that uh to terrible world of media we
live in oh good in the last few years
independent journalists have been
gaining a lot of traction
yeah they're gonna be our only hope in
it but they're gonna have to somehow
try and unify people
you know what I mean even when I just
did there like but that's why I try to
trash CNN and fox I'm not trying to
divide people I'm trying to get people
out from underneath
listening to them you know what I mean
it's like you ever be with somebody and
like they they they I don't know they
just
they have a bad manager they have a
[__] up parent they just have somebody
that they just turned over all of this
you know a boyfriend or a girlfriend
that you're just trying to get them out
of that zombified [__] state
into uh my world of intelligence
sorry every once in a while I get up on
the stump and then I'm like wait what am
I doing I went to summer school
um anyway let's continue reading here
also I'd like to add a glimmer of hope
to terrible
world media we live in the last few
years independent journals have been
getting a lot of traction the most
interesting thing is that Progressive
leaning and conservative leaning
independent journalists agree on a lot
oh my God
is this a prank
that's what I'm hoping will happen check
out Rising on the hill Network they run
daily shows on YouTube that cover the
news in the same way
yeah I like Jimmy Dore agree with them
or not I like Jimmy Dore Jimmy Dore
seems to be holding everybody
accountable which is why I feel like he
gets attacked all the time
uh oh trouble in this Sue is
Billy Joel I actually looked that up
uh we didn't start the fire
here's all my excuses to not be a good
person all right trouble in the Suez
it's likely referring to the war that
happened in the Suez Canal in Egypt in
the 60s or something there's been
several historic events surrounding
issues with it although most recently
that cargo ship that got wedged in it
trying to do a [__] U-turn or some
[__] that was fantastic
that was fantastic I thought you were
actually going to go into what happened
I actually looked it up and for what I
can remember it was um
I think there was a transfer of power
where Egypt had the audacity
to want to control the canal
and then other people say well [__]
Britain or America whoever built it but
it's gonna be like well who did they
build it with slave labor probably with
Egyptians and then there's all of these
different
stats on how many people died like 120
000 people is the height and then
somebody else is like it's only like 3
000 people
imagine if you built well a football
stadium isn't a comparable thing because
it's just a football stadium there
actually was literally separating
Africa
a continent from Asia right you used to
be able to walk from Asia to [__]
Africa right
um
yeah so then then there was this big
fight the Israelis came in engaged and
then we had to come in and defend the
Israelis I think I don't know what
happened but uh it just seems It's the
usual
stuff over there
that was trouble in this Suez
uh could you write a book
hey Billy Bob
hey Billy Bob thunder thighs
um I just pictured Phil Hartman when he
was
being Bill Clinton going for a jog and
stopping at McDonald's that sketch and I
also remember when Bill Clinton used to
go running and he wore those short
shorts and he had those giant like
[__]
milky thighs
I've listened to the podcast since high
school and I'm a fan of your work I know
that you can't read all that great but I
wondered if you'd ever write a book
I'm reading Matthew McConaughey's book
green Lads and I've been thinking how
great it would be to hear oh Billy's
memoir
I bet you've got some wisdom to share
somewhere in that dented pumpkin head
come on man I got enough Hang-Ups I
don't even know my head needs Bondo uh
good luck on your 100th I've been
working out routine
we need you around for your [__] jokes
go [__] yourself hey [__] you man stop
acting like you found out uh uh
a workout plan and you stuck with it and
didn't start and stop
all right I don't need this [__] you
heard what happened I kept saying how
many times did I have to tell my wife
I'm going to the gym I'm going to the
gym I'm going to the gym right because
she wants to go on go get [__] coffee
you know because she's in she's she's
living her best life
she got her revenge body for the [__]
Christmas season or whatever the [__]
you're supposed to do all right next
Giants in the USA
Giants in the USA this looks interesting
as hell hey Bill have you seen this
the book begins with this quote from
Abraham Lincoln in 1848.
Giants were clearly a real thing to him
now this is his quote the eyes of that
species of extinct Giants whose bones
fill the Mounds of America have gazed on
Niagara as ours do now
wow what a slick way
to just completely
go around organize religion not even
addressed it but dunk in their face by
saying that
you know what I bet that is just a big
of reason that he got [__]
assassinated you have to organize
religion or if you say you know what
maybe we shouldn't oppress other people
those are the two [__] biggest ways
to get yourself whacked
um there have been hundreds of sites or
not giving them a war there's been
hundreds of sites with giant bones
buried in them discovered across the USA
in the last 400 years why wouldn't we
talk about that that's fascinating
why do people have a problem with the
fact that we're not the only thing in
the universe
it's not good for business in the name
of the Father the Son the yamaka and the
[__] whatever else you're [__]
into and many documented in newspaper
articles from the 19th century which are
shown in the book in the last 150 years
the Bones have tended to go to the
Smithsonian where they disappear
dude
what level of wealth do you have to get
to
you know what I mean will you live
forever you see the giant bones
you know
you're talking to aliens they take you
up on the spaceships
right
maybe that's what happens maybe that's
the the Illuminati level rich people
maybe they don't die
they just fake their death and they get
on a flying saucer and then they go to a
new maybe that's why they're not worried
about global warming because they can
get to another planet they're like I
will wear this there's hundreds of
millions of Earth
if you got the transportation
dude that's a great sci-fi movie
all right Mel Gibson drives a cab hear
me out he's driving a cab in his
conspiracy
is that the super rich
are keep going around from Earth to
Earth around around the universe or the
solars
system gamma ray whatever the [__] you
call it
um and they uh they just keep using up
countries I mean planets and destroying
the planets and leaving all these people
behind
but why would that be bad
but then they're kind of keeping the
race going human race going
that'd be [__] hilarious if that if
they actually do that and then when this
country's going under they're like a
human like uh
like maybe that's the thing that they
left off of Noah's Ark maybe Noah's Ark
wasn't actually an ark it was a [__]
Flying Saucer and not only did he grab
two [__] animals from each species
which really doesn't work out because
they would all be interbred like [__]
Dalmatians right
um maybe they did they do that with
people too
to white people to black people two
Asians two latino through the whole
[__] thing
you'd have to get more than that that
never works then math never works out on
that
um
and as much as uh
as much as organized religion comes down
on people [__] around it's the
swingers
that probably got us out of the inbred
the inbredness of Adam and Eve
you know what I mean like at some point
somebody had to like [__] you know
I don't know stretch it out a little bit
uh anyway I don't know what I'm talking
about am I a banker [__]
dear Billy Bank Buster I'm a former
police officer and current anti-money
laundering analysts
that's got to be a fascinating job
catching these people doing this [__]
um I work for a private contractor that
provides money laundering fraud and
General Financial crime Investigation
Services to large and small Banks
worldwide I was curious to get your
opinion on my line of work
wait you do this for what
large and small Banks well small banks
are cool right well for the most part
contract it provides money lining 500
this investigation okay
uh well you just sort of working for the
bank I don't know but I mean you I don't
I wouldn't say you're a banker [__]
because it's also like
them not paying taxes on it causes them
to charge
regular people I.E people like me who
don't know how to launder money
before I act like I'm a good person I'd
launder money if I knew how to do it
if it wasn't so difficult I could have a
[__] side business I don't want to do
all that I gotta go through the Canary
Islands just take what you're gonna take
I don't give a [__]
um anyway I was curious to get your
opinion on my line of work
as you always take the banks to task and
call them out on their [__] all of
which I agree with ultimately the reason
my job exists and the reason Banks hire
my services is to cover their own ass
and avoid sanctions and monetary Terry
loss at the same time though I feel the
work I do is genuinely helpful to people
I I would agree with that and also if
they start losing money they're not Lo
they don't lose money they pass it on to
the to the to the jerk-offs that work
all week and put their money in there so
you're
helping to prevent a bank from failing
and when a bank fails the people running
the bank keep all their money
we all get [__] anyways examples of
some of the things I investigate include
human trafficking I mean that's one of
the greatest things you could ever try
and stop
terrorist financing fantastic and Elder
Financial abuse all right wait a minute
wait a minute I feel like you're acting
like you don't know what you know I
don't know am I a good guy
I feel like you're you're reaching out
for compliments here you're trying to
stop
[__] pedophiles pimps terrorists and
people that take advantage of old people
am I as bad as your Bankers
I know what you're doing
I know when somebody's [__] searching
for a oh you [__] I'll never get
those five minutes back that it took me
to read those four sentences
I mean I'm helping old people across the
street does that make me bad too
you know maybe this isn't you maybe this
is the Cheesesteak you know but it's not
this cheese steak it's the fried onions
and all of the other [__] [__] on
there you know what's funny is I
actually bonded with uh Joe bartnick who
was an amazing special out
um we're just putting the clips out and
this whole special is going to drop all
things comedy uh look for those clips
his special is just like you watch it
you like it feels like it was shot now
and also it could have been any time
before that it's just timeless
it's just fan it's fantastic I'm so
proud to have my name on that special
um
anyway
I just completely [__] I just went
down that [__] road I completely
forgot what I was going to
what was I was talking about
cheesesteaks I was talking about human
trafficking I was talking about
laundering money
I was talking about uh giant people
flying saucers Mel Gibson yep it's gone
just like that
and just like that it's gone you know
what else is gone my time to do this
podcast because I have to go to the gym
I am on the green shirt diet Billy green
shirt all right my wife bought me this
beautiful
you know
British racing green button-down shirt
and I've never been able to get into it
because she got it right as the pandemic
was kicking in and I've been walking
around this [__] waiting it [__]
ends now all right I'm going to the gym
go [__] yourselves and I'll check in on
you on Thursday